Kru it he's small unassuming he's a good
of a but he's also the strongest
earthling and I'm going to show you why
I'm totally not mark and this is the
power level Theory episode 3 curling
Krillin is a human type earthling aged
43 to 44 taking into account 132 days he
spent dead his techniques include the
solar flare the Kamehameha and the ki an
saan otherwise known as the Destructo
disc there are six officially stated
power levels for current those being 206
one thousand seven hundred and seventy
one thousand five hundred over ten
thousand thirteen thousand and finally
75 thousand during the time period
between the 22nd Budokai and Raddatz
Crillon trains with Roshi and Goku on
and off with little motivation other
than for a portion of that to surpass
Goku over the course of those eight
years crows power level rises from wash
to be roughly 130 when he faces Master
Roshi to 206 by the time Riots dies
which is an increase of sixty percent
overall similar to Roshi Bulma uses a
modified scatter to read chromed power
level after rats dice it raves 206
Krillin along with the other Z warriors
then go to train with commie in
preparation for the Seine invasion for
approximately one year and in that time
period Crillon boosts his power from a
reading of 206 to 1770 which is an
increase of 8.5 x skipping ahead Crillon
and Gohan land dynamic and are already
attracting attention due to their above
average power levels however the most
significant measurable boost in power
Crillon receives comes from guru when he
draws out his hidden power this one is
sort of difficult to pin down it is
stated that jury has battled agudo his
power had grown from the mid 1002 1001
interesting is that in Dyson qu 7 while
Crillon is fighting raccoon and I used
the term fighting loosely his power
level has already risen to 13,000 this
is important as it gives us evidence to
support the case that Gru's power boosts
work on a gradual but steady increment
in the short amount of time between
bulldoze death and crows altercation
with recruit he has already increased by
almost 3000 and even though he wasn't a
match for the big bags of the ark his
power level increased dramatically
during the events of Namek topping off a
whopping power level of 75,000 by the
time Frieza kills him this is the
increase that made it
impossible for tension on Yamcha and
Roshi to catch up this was the increase
that made Krug the absolute strongest
earthly once he has revived after 132
days there is no mention of training by
crew after the news of the androids drop
he begins training with Roshi for three
years
perhaps with Goku also but again this is
just guesswork based on their
relationship the only training reference
I have regarding cronin is the 8th year
time span between the 22nd Budokai and
the ratted saga again during this time
he increased by about 60% so what's
different the androids arrival has left
Crillon highly motivated he has improved
greatly since then but the time frame
for improvement is significantly less
all that considered I think an 80%
increase will suffice it took him eight
years to get that kind of an increase
before but now that he has the correct
motivation and is more experienced he
can achieve that in 3 years of intense
training bringing his power level up to
135,000 by the time the androids touched
down during the Android and cell saga
Crillon isn't really used in a fighting
capacity mainly there to help guide our
sympathy for the androids angle overall
never entering the time chamber or scene
to Train even what's moving on to the
Buu saga both Toriyama and Yamcha state
that of all the Earthlings Crillon is
the strongest Gohan however states that
Crillon no longer fights but using that
there is no way of knowing whether or
not Quillin stops fighting recently or a
long time ago
judging from the length of his hair it
could have been a number of years ago
eight years have passed and so perhaps
I'll give him a diminishment of about 5%
taking into account that for a year or
two he may have kept up his training but
honestly this is incredibly hard to
judge taking that diminishment into
account
Krillin now has a power level of one
hundred and twenty eight thousand two
hundred and fifty by the end of the Buu
saga once the Buu saga concludes over
the six years leading up to the events
of episode 75
Krillin does not train and therefore I
will diminish his strength I think a
diminishment of about 10% seems fair it
is however important to note that his
biggest problem is that he doesn't
believe in himself that his own mind
blocks his true potential as a fighter
leaving Crillon with a power level of
115 thousand 425 krune's biggest problem
super and really the only store he's had
a leading role in despair is his self
belief or lack thereof he may have a
power level near the 120,000 but because
of his lack of self belief he doesn't
access or use the strength to its
fullest potential I'd like in this on
some level to Gohan streamer mind when
he touched down at the beginning of the
saying invasion Gohan would be set up by
both Crillon and piccolo but would
freeze instead of fight the funny thing
I think about this example is that
Crillon was the one swallowing his fear
in that scene what happened well Krillin
was always very realistic throughout
Dragonball and knew his limitations it's
one of the reasons why he's a very
interesting character but that never
stopped him from participating in the
action throughout Dragonball and well
into Z but something happened to his
character in the freezer saga killed in
a malicious and frankly terrifying
looking way powerless to do anything I
believe this is the root of why Crillon
was more doubtful of his abilities as a
fighter thereafter he did however always
maintain a great ability to sense how
strong his opponent and the people
around him weren't and honestly that's
the problem as this list goes on you'll
see that these power level estimates get
crazier and crazier
Krillin is a human the strongest human
at that according to Akira Toriyama so
during and after freezes arc he was
faced with challenges he really could
contribute middle to this continues as
honestly gets worse and worse throughout
the buuck ultimately coming to a head in
supras resurrection of that chapter
we're in Crillon even though he is
surrounded by his closest friends who
are themselves skilled fighters is
frozen by fear unable to bring himself
to fight back he completely lost touch
with his self belief and reality
reassurance from his friends keeps him
in that fight but this was a first for
fully grown adult Crillon overestimating
someone he had gotten so used to being a
spectator that he never considered he
would be worth anything in a fight
anymore
then came episode 75 and 76 I'm
Dragonball super in their light a great
story about quillin's finding his self
belief once again finding the ability to
cam and focus his ki and mind I believe
this instance really helped Crillon gain
greater strength emotionally and
otherwise having only fought a super
Shenron delusion it's really difficult
to gauge how strong he is now because
honestly this is territory we haven't
seen crews set foot in since the
the Nanak saga he can now focus on
what's important to him like protecting
his family it's fair to assume that
before this enlightenment phase for
curling and Dragon Ball super tension on
would have wiped the floor with him
not because Crillon couldn't compare but
because he couldn't believe he could it
really is mind over matter his power
level I believe remains in the region of
115 thousand 425 but after the zen state
was achieved it's hard to know if he is
in fact stronger or if he wasn't able to
tap into his full potential due to
mental blocks prior to this reawakening
only time will tell I guess it's
possible that this state grants him
greater power I however think it's more
likely a form of key control and
manipulation instead of flaring around
his body his aura seems canned as well
as focused in his hands ready for combat
again this could be a sign of greater
power but there was literally nothing
known about this form when it pertains
to boost and strength
anyone who has watched Koreans
performances in Dragonball knows how fun
it is to see him participate in a
tournament with moves like the ki an
saan and his new Zen state added to his
arsenal I honestly can't wait to see him
in a tournament setting again and
honestly it wouldn't be as fun without
him he's easily one of my favorite
characters now what do you guys think
Rome's power level is leave a comment
down below letting me know your thoughts
if you enjoyed this video feel free to
leave a like and if you want to see more
videos like this rumor has it there's a
really nice little subscribe button
beneath this video I don't know why
don't you give it a click see what
happens this has been the power level
series as always I've been told not mark
thank you so much for watching
oh three down seven to go something
tells me that these are going to get
progressively more and more difficult
and complex as I go up and yeah I love
Krillin he's always been one of my
favorite characters even though he has
pretty much no redeemable battle
qualities in a battle series like Dragon
Ball oh also if you guys want like
specific kinds of videos like if you
want me to do top tens on a specific
topic or if you guys have any
suggestions for any videos at all just
leave a comment down below and I'll read
all - I read pretty much every comments
oh oh oh also thank you for the huge
amount of positive feedback in the last
video I really appreciate that this
series is pretty much going to be every
single week until we run out of universe
7 team members I'll upload every
Wednesday at 2
p.m. East Coast time it's going to be a
fun show if you guys would like to see
more of this subscribe if you don't
thanks for watching I guess I don't know
maybe I'm weird um I definitely am I'm
editing this at three in the morning
awesome
don't say I don't try guys don't say I
don't try right so I better get back to
work on the next guy
it should be fun should be controversial
perhaps even more controversial than
chrome being stronger than Tian so I'm
going to go hit the old dusty trail and
bye dusty trail any bad and by hit I
mean sleep so yeah I'm going to go sleep
in my bed or my dusty trail whatever you
want to call it later guys
you